[Music]
push-ups
yep you're a great to do this with me
okay
ladies especially I know you hate
push-ups it is not easy and it can be
very challenging but if you one tone
showed us arms and also a firm chest
do not skip your push-ups so I'm gonna
challenge you to do 100 pushups you need
10 variations 10 repetitions each and I
want you to let me know what is your
best timing in the comments below okay
let's do this together
we're going to start with some easy
push-ups and we're going to fill it up
okay stay with me let's do this together
right let's start with knee push-ups
okay so get onto your knees if you want
to go onto your toes ten repetitions for
this one let's go one two easy just warm
up your chest three four five six so
spread your elbows eight last two nine
last one ten go low okay next tricep
push-ups to bring both arms closer to
your chest okay
point your elbows back and this will
work more on your triceps let's go one
two
I'll go side three close to your chest
four five halfway there one two three
four five very good that's 20 down okay
now we're going to combine it the first
two workouts and do in out push-ups
okay so we're gonna hop in let's go down
one hop in two out three four combined
five you just start to feel a chest six
seven eight
9 plus 1/10 good oh my god can you feel
your chest and your arms right let's
continue to show the top three shops so
now you get on to your toes all right so
you're gonna go down one tap one
shoulder and - good
tap three balance good for whoa five six
four more seven eight go lower if you
can nine tap last one ten and tap right
shake it all it's a bit spider member
who shops okay
again choose your options you can get on
to your toes or on your knees okay shake
it out a little bit
let's go spider-man push up you down and
hop okay to go low three good reach four
five six seven eight
try to touch nine last vitamin go down
touch and up good stagger push up okay
this will focus more on one side of your
chest so you can choose to start with
your knees if you want bring your right
palm forward left palm back okay and
same thing go low and push up good go
low and push good five repetitions for
one side you can load up two more up
last one good
now change if you want to get onto your
toes okay good one good two up three up
four up last one fine good so you were
really target one side each and it is
good if you find that your chest muscles
are in balance next push up and twist
okay you want to open up and twist ready
normal push up down
and twist good let's go to down and
twist three down twist pull and twist
five keep going
I can feel you six last four seven eight
push up nine twist one more side down
and twist shake it out a little bit
dress it up a little bit door finish up
but don't a push up get on to your
elbows okay it's really about hiking
your butt up
alright let's get on into a plank
position
okay I want you to take your butt up to
your arms down over your chin
ah okay good let's go one hike over to
good over three good this will really
work more on your arms for over five
keep going halfway there
six Pike seven last three more eight
push through your lower back as well
ninth your arms and last one ten very
good plank up down okay so it is some
sort of push up and coming up so let's
start on a low plank ready let's go 1 2
change 3 keep your core tight your body
straight before 5
six seven eight see your sweat dripping
night last 110 and down all right one
final push out okay
dive Bombur push out okay you're gonna
dive like a bummer man all right so
let's do it start in a high plank okay
Pike your butt up dumb pop up and dive
you look up three nice four five
stay with me six this is not easy
seven last three stay with me here's
week eight Pike plus 2/9 stay with me oh
my god
last time last one and ten push up and
Oh No
just get into a child pose and just
stretch your upper body out that was 100
oh my gosh my arms all right again well
done you did 100 pushups okay ten
variations again if you're a beginner
you can start on your knees and then
slowly progress onto your toes if you're
a guy hey but all means get into your
toes speed up the work out and let me
know what is your best timing in the
comments below I can really feel my
shoulders my arms are dying so I
challenge you to share this video with a
friends get it to join you in this
challenge and see who does better okay
like this video subscribe to my youtube
channel for a lot more crazy workout
challenges fitness tips and also healthy
recipes don't forget to turn on your
notification button so that you will get
notified every time I share a new video
the best